[Music]
identity and access management or IIM in
Google Cloud gives you fine-grained
control over permissions but it can be
complex to manage the iam policy
troubleshooter tool can help in
investigating issues as to why a user
has access to a resource or doesn't have
permission to call an API let's walk
through how to use the policy
troubleshooter we can access policy
troubleshooter using the cloud console
the g-cloud command line tool or the
REST API for simple queries using the
cloud console is easy and includes a
visual aid for more complex scenarios
consider using the g-cloud tool or the
REST API in this video we'll focus on
using policy troubleshooter through the
cloud console and getting the details of
a project first off we'll need three
parameters to use policy troubleshooter
principal resource and permission the
principal field is the email address to
check which can refer to a user or a
service account let's use a user account
with the email user at TSE Jeunet the
resource field is the full name of the
resource we want to test against the
path of the full name varies depending
on the resource type for example the
path for our project is cloud resource
manager Google api's comm slash projects
slash my project you can see a full list
of resource names in the documentation
or you can use the autocomplete function
the permission field is the permission
we're checking the user for similar to
the resource field a list of permissions
will be presented as we start to type
let's use a resource manager dot
projects that get which grants access to
retrieve the project for a complete list
of permissions check the permissions
reference documentation the required
permission to access a resource may also
be displayed as part of a permission
denied error you can always refer to the
specific product documentation page for
a list of roles and permissions that are
required to access the resources we can
also add additional resources and
permissions to check for the principle
by clicking on add additional pair if
desired
we'll click on check API call and a
results page will come up by default the
results will be displayed in compact
view which will only show the roles that
contain the permission that we've
checked for
we can click the toggle to see the full
view displaying all the roles for our
resources IIM policy at the top of the
page we can quickly see whether the user
is granted the permission on the
resource we can see that our user has
the permission for resource manager dot
projects not yet in our project
additional details on the policy results
are also displayed below the first
warning you do not have permission to
view all policy bindings may occur if
this is a resource that's under an
organization the user doesn't have the
permission to view higher call iam
policies on the organization and/or the
folder levels to resolve this the user
would need a role such as security
reviewer at the organization level the
second warning you do not have
permission to view specific group
memberships may be due to the user not
having group admin permissions to
resolve this a G suite administrator
could grant the user a role with the
group stat read permission the left pane
contains a list of roles that apply to
the given resource and an icon which
shows if our user has a binding to that
role we can click on the role to
highlight the specifics the green check
next to the owner role indicates that
this binding grants access to our user
the right pane displays the raw text of
each binding highlighting each line for
the roles and members lines that don't
match our user are shown in red and ones
that match or green yellow means that
the policy troubleshooter can't evaluate
the binding in this case it's likely due
to the warning earlier about the lack of
permissions to view group memberships
read more about the policy
troubleshooter in the documentation
[Music]